c'est plutôt tendue aux postes de
contrôle qui sépare la moldavie du
territoire de la transnistrie un soldat
nous a laissé entrer après une série de
questions mais c'est en tant que tout
restait qu'avec nos téléphones pour
filmer que nous avons réussi à pénétrer
dans cette petite enclave séparatiste
pro russe où l'état d' alerte est en
vigueur depuis la fin du mois d'avril au
delà des barrages si le calme plat
difficile d'imaginer à première vue que
la guerre pourrait s'étendre jusque ici
mais l'ukraine et à deux kilomètres du
dima et ce sont des nazis ils peuvent
nous attaquer n'importe quand ils l'ont
déjà fait
comme tant d'autres dima 3 tout ce que
le kremlin est raconté à la télévision
la propagande russe fait partie du
quotidien ici et elle est convaincant
ce sont les ukrainiens qui tue les
leurres di maria même si elle a accès
aux chaînes du monde entier elle se fit
aux nouvelles de moscou
avec nostalgie crachoir
évidemment
c'est la russie qui nous nourrit c'est
la russie qui nous traite bien nous
sommes des amis depuis l'ère soviétique
ça fait plus de trente ans que la
transnistrie a fait sécession de la
moldavie avec le soutien de moscou
trente ans que la russie sans
reconnaître son autonomie la contrôler
avec plus de 1500 trop présentes à
l'année longue la capitale tiraspol est
à l'image des vieilles villes
soviétiques avec sa statue de lenine la
faucille et le marteau comme oublier
figé dans le temps jamal zahalka devenir
stocks sur bellamy
sur bloody gelli on est bien comme ça et
on veut pas la guerre on veut la paix du
galinat sur un ton désespéré
qu'à 100 km à 4 la part et elle est
consciente que son petit bout de pays
est au coeur des préoccupations
internationales qu'on craint de voir le
kremlin utiliser ce territoire
russophone pour ouvrir un nouveau front
dans sa conquête de l'ukraine des
craintes amplifié parce général de
l'armée russe qui a déclaré que le
contrôle du site de l'ukraine servirait
de couloir vers la transnistrie où
dit-il on observe également des cadeaux
pression de la population russophone
quelques jours plus tard trois
explosions ont secoué la région de tours
de radio une vieille caserne militaire
ont été détruits
moscou a crié à l'attack
terrorisme à ce
qu'a
dit que c'est l'ukraine qui nous a
attaqués avec des drones affirme galina
mais elle n'en sait pas plus
et c'est exactement le genre de panique
et de chaos que moscou et celle générée
pour justifier une intervention
militaire selon nicolaï qui a tellement
peur d'être mobilisés qu'ils songent à
partir comme l'ont fait beaucoup
d'autres de son
agence
nous n'avons croisé à la banque cotée
moldave où il est venu déposer de
l'argent il n'a que 18 ans et dit que
l'effort séparatiste de transnistrie ont
déjà commencé à recruter des jeunes
il ne veut pas se battre ni contre
l'ukraine ni contre les moldaves avec
qui cohabitent en paix et puis sa
naissance des soldats comme juli
propriétaire du garage du village il dit
qu'il prie le bon dieu pour que l'armée
ukrainienne barrent la route aux russes
avant bourse chif
sa femme le milan nous rejoint et les
ukrainiennes je documente sur le coeur
[Musique]
elle refuse de concevoir une défaite de
l'ukraine ce n'est pas une option
envisageable existenz lynch entre autres
[Musique]
non
elle se cale où tous les jours en
chantant c'était son gagne pain
elle travaillait avant la guerre pour
une chorale en transnistrie mais refuse
d'y remettre les pieds depuis que son
patron lui a dit que l'ukraine mérité ce
qui lui arrive
les tensions redouté entre moldaver pro
russe gagne ainsi du terrain et avec
chaque bond qui tombe au loin sur rodez
à la guerre se rapproche du juli et le
millas espère le mieux mais se prépare
au pire c'est dans la cave à vin qu'ils
iront se cacher en cas d'atteinte
le miller dit que sa fille lui demande
souvent moi ma tête de chien
pourquoi un pays grand comme la russie
aura besoin de l'ukraine ou de la petite
moldavie et mondo van dai ichi achats
les semaines pas si la guerre continue
[Musique]
elle ne sait toujours pas quoi lui
répondre